a estos conceptos que se utilizan
muchísimo cuando se habla acerca de
macroeconomía que son la política
monetaria y la política fiscal ahorita
en este vídeo lo que vamos a hacer es
platicar de qué se tratan en que son
diferentes y para qué sirven entonces
déjame le escribo por aquí arriba
monetaria para política monetaria
monetaria y de este lado voy a poner
fiscal fiscal sale estas dos básicamente
son dos herramientas que tiene el
gobierno para desplazar la curva de
demanda agregada hacia la derecha es
decir para estimular el consumo o para
estimular la demanda de modo que la
curva esta que habíamos visto en la
gráfica se mueva para la derecha vale
ahorita lo que vamos a ver es quiénes
son los actores y cómo le hacen
específicamente para desplazar esta
demanda hacia la derecha bueno entonces
vamos a empezar con política monetaria
vale política monetaria básicamente se
trata de imprimir dinero le voy a poner
aquí imprimir
e imprimir dinero esto quiere decir que
va a servir para meter o sacar dinero de
la circulación va quién es el actor
principal aquí o sea quién está
encargado de imprimir dinero pues un
banco central le voy a poner aquí banco
central central y por ejemplo en méxico
el banco central sería el banco de
méxico le voy a poner por aquí banco
banco de méxico méxico esta institución
es una institución que usualmente es
independiente del gobierno o es autónoma
y que está encargada de varias cosas
financieras dentro de la economía por
ejemplo el banco de méxico pues es pues
semi autónomo semi independiente o sea
si es una institución independiente
puede tomar sus propias decisiones pero
está muy entrelazada con el gobierno
porque por ejemplo su junta de gobierno
del banco de méxico la propone el
presidente y luego el senado aprueba esa
propuesta y pues también no se tiene que
rendir informes al congreso de la unión
sin embargo en cuanto a su gestión
administrativa si es autónomo vale
bueno entre las funciones de un banco
central digamos del banco de méxico está
el derecho a imprimir dinero entonces le
voy a poner por acá imprimir dinero
cuando no le pongo nada más le voy a
poner aquí billete un billete que el
banco va a imprimir y en realidad pues
digo imprimir dinero puede ser así en
forma de papel pero también se puede
imprimir dinero entre comillas creando
lo de manera electrónica y de hecho casi
todo el dinero que se crea en la
actualidad es de manera electrónica
bueno lo que va a pasar con este billete
de acá es que no se van a comprar cosas
así en el mercado pues bueno si se van a
comprar cosas en el mercado pero no se
van a comprar bienes y servicios
directos de la economía ok lo que va a
hacer el banco de mexico con estos
billetes es comprar deuda me voy a poner
por aquí comprar
comprar deuda y puede sonar un poco raro
esto de comprar deuda pero básicamente
comprar deuda es lo mismo que prestar
dinero si esto es lo mismo que prestar
prestar dinero dinero y a quién le va a
prestar dinero a pues no va a ir con
cualquiera con fulanito y le va a decir
te voy a prestar dinero no más bien lo
que va a hacer el banco de mexico es
comprar pagarés gubernamentales o bien
va a comprar bonos de empresas muy muy
seguras va a comprar bonos de muy bajo
riesgo entonces el banco de mexico
imprime los billetes va al mercado
abierto ve en cuánto están los bonos a
quien se los puede comprar entonces
compra bonos del gobierno federal sin
bonos gubernamentales o bien de una
empresa muy muy segura entonces con esto
que sucede el banco de méxico está
metiendo billetes al sistema monetario y
entonces vamos a hacer una gráfica para
ver qué sucede mira vamos a irnos
ahorita nada más a la microeconomía
vámonos a un contexto micro
ahorita pasamos al contexto macro
vámonos al contexto micro económico del
dinero que micro del dinero dinero
entonces en este contexto tenemos lo
siguiente voy a pintar los ejes de este
lado tenemos el precio del dinero que ya
platicamos mucho de que el precio de
dinero es la tasa de interés y de este
lado déjame bajar un poquito por aquí
aquí tenemos el precio del dinero que es
la tasa de interés de interés y de este
lado de acá tenemos la oferta de dinero
oferta sale entonces ahí tenemos interés
oferta ahorita lo que voy a dibujar es
la demanda de dinero
entre la gráfica de la demanda de dinero
y la gráfica de oferta es algo de este
estilo tiene pendiente positiva verdad
entonces esto de aquí es la oferta estoy
aquí es la demanda aquí más que oferta
debería decir como como cantidad ok y
supongamos que habita el dinero tiene un
cierto precio entonces aquí a esta
altura el dinero tiene un precio más o
menos como por acá digamos una tasa de
interés de 5 por ciento ok entonces qué
sucede aquí arriba que sucede una vez
que el banco de méxico- imprime dinero y
este dinero entra al sistema monetario
pasa este dinero que entra al sistema
monetario y no va a parar así a los
colchones verdad sino que empieza a
entrar a esta cosa de acá hay una mayor
cantidad de dinero entonces esta curva
se va a desplazar hacia la derecha a la
curva de oferta verdad para cada
cantidad fija vamos a tener una mayor
oferta de dinero y entonces va a moverse
digamos como por acá
y algo de este estilo va a quedar
indicado aquí y entonces qué sucede qué
sucede con el nuevo nivel de precio y
qué sucede también con la demanda mira
el nuevo nivel de precio va a bajar
digamos a 3% y la demanda va a aumentar
digamos qué pasó no sé qué antes pedían
100 miles de millones de pesos y ahora
va a pasar a 120 este miles de millones
de pesos entonces qué sucede pues mira
ahora la tasa de interés baja antes
había personas que digamos tenían
proyectos de 4% o de 4.5 por ciento que
no les convenía pedir prestado dinero
porque si se financiaban de todas formas
salían perdiendo pero ahora cuando baja
esta tasa cuando baja la tasa de interés
la gente puede pues finalmente ir al
banco y es pedir prestado también hay
otra razón y bueno
por la cual se puede generar más consumo
y así que en vez de inversiones que la
gente vaya al banco y en vez de invertir
lo consuma pero esto de la inversión
tiene mucho más sentido o sea si tienes
un proyecto de 4% y la tasa de interés
está al 3% pues te conviene realizarlo
porque con eso pues puedes hacer una
ganancia del 1% vale entonces esa es la
idea baja el precio y con eso aumenta
aumenta la inversión entonces pues ahí
va vámonos
con esto de acá aumenta la inversión
aumenta la demanda de dinero baje el
precio y entonces ahora sí vámonos a un
contexto macroeconómico lo voy a poner
acá a la derecha y le voy a poner macro
macro y entonces ahora sí vamos a pensar
todo en términos macroeconómicos vale
aquí tenemos el eje aquí tenemos el otro
eje
y algo de este estilo luego tenemos de
este lado precios pero acuérdate que
este es precio agregado
aquí tenemos producto interno bruto real
y vamos a dibujar la curva de demanda
agregada estoy acá quedamos que tiene
pendiente negativa demanda agregada y
además vamos a poner la oferta agregada
a corto plazo
no voy a poner así ahí me quedo un poco
hecho de acá dejó de jala vuelvo a
pintar estaré acá va creciendo cada vez
con una mayor pendiente y esta es la
oferta agregada
a corto plazo muy bien entonces qué
sucede ahora en un contexto
macroeconómico pues ahora tenemos que
las personas pidieron prestado más
empiezan a tener más inversión no
empiezan a tener más consumo de modo que
acá en la macroeconomía aún mayor bueno
para un nivel de precio dado ahora
tenemos pues una este mayor demanda
verdad y entonces esto también hace que
se desplace la curva de demanda agregada
hacia la derecha vamos a ponerlo por acá
algo de este estilo entonces esta curva
se desplaza para allá
eso está re bueno verdad la demanda
agregada aumenta y entonces esa es una
forma de desplazarlo y también pasa al
revés o sea si el banco puede retirar
dinero de circulación vendiendo su deuda
y entonces debemos mirar podemos hacer
que la curva de demanda agregada se
desplace hacia la izquierda bueno esto
es política monetaria que tiene que ver
con imprimir dinero pasemos ahora a la
política fiscal y para pensar en la
política fiscal ahora sí vamos a pensar
que el gobierno va y consume bienes y
servicios directamente de la economía
vale y cómo le hace el gobierno para
hacer esto pues por acá está el gobierno
está el gobierno y básicamente tiene dos
formas de financiarse una es a través de
impuestos impuestos
pues estos y la otra es a través de
deuda deuda
entonces de repente si el gobierno
decide gastar más osea puede decir voy a
empezar a comprar más bienes de la
economía voy a empezar a comprar tanques
o lo que sea entonces el gobierno puede
ir y puedes meter ese dinero a la
economía vamos a ponerle aquí gasto
gasto si entonces digamos si deja los
impuestos fijos tendría que aumentar su
deuda tendría ahora
bueno en vez de de prestar dinero
tendría que pedir prestado emite bonos
ese dinero lo utiliza entonces entra en
deuda le entra la deuda y con eso le
entra el gasto y de esta forma también
podemos hacer que se desplace la curva
de demanda agregada hacia la derecha o
bien hacia la izquierda si el gobierno
decide hacer lo contrario bueno ya nada
más para recapitular entonces estas dos
cosas la política monetaria y la
política fiscal son herramientas para
desplazar la curva de demanda agregada
hacia la derecha o hacia la izquierda
pero casi siempre es para desplazarla
hacia la derecha va de este lado la
política monetaria consiste en que una
institución
esté un poco más indirecta algo así como
el banco central en caso de méxico sería
el banco de méxico- imprime dinero ese
dinero entra al sistema con eso logra
aumentar la oferta de dinero baja las
tasas de interés y entonces aumenta la
inversión o bien aumenta el consumo eso
desplaza en la curva hacia la izquierda
o hacia la derecha según se quiera y acá
del lado de la política fiscal es que el
gobierno directamente a través de sus
impuestos oa través de deuda decide
aumentar su gasto y con eso se desplaza
la curva de demanda agregada hacia la
izquierda o hacia la derecha